as a teenager in Iran I used to listen
to the BBC and similar radio stations as
the voice of the liberal West and as a
beacon of democracy and hope and all
that and then once I got here I thought
that that the BBC obviously had changed
a lot everything is changing here you
know I just found myself to be working
for them for mouthpiece of uh you know
globalist agenda when I started doing
comedy I did one of those Unleashed gigs
and it went well the The Spectator run a
feature and the article somehow made its
way to my boss's desks and they're my
disciplinary troubles started so you go
on any famous BBC presenters Twitter
feed most of them the Gary linekers they
get a free ride whereas in my case they
said no you can't you can't do that and
ultimately I was put on final written
warning and I thought okay I'm I need to
I need to change my job
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is a
somewhat controversial comedian and
YouTuber who we know back from our
comedy circuit there's Nicholas DeSanto
welcome to trigonometry hello guys
thanks for inviting me it's really good
to have you a lot of people have
suggested when you just did the
headliners on GB news people were like
it's great to see Constantine on there
oh I get that a lot yeah but welcome to
the show before we get into it uh tell
everybody who are you uh how are you
where you are what has been your journey
through life that leads you to be
sitting here talking to us
um what a wonderful question thanks for
having me I was telling Francis the
other day that I'll Make History by
being the least famous guest of
trigonometry ever by coming on the show
my name is Nicolas DeSanto I'm a comic
based in North London Italian Iranian
originally naturalized Brits I started
um
pursuing my comedy career if you will by
doing a course taught by Francis Foster
actually so he was my first commentary
instructor sitting right next to you
yeah and then I started gigging on the
comedy circuit the ups and downs
obviously because my material is a bit
um
or more than a bit right-wing or
conservative then covet happened the big
blow to Comedy circuit regardless of
your angles
and then I I resumed after covet like
all of us did and here I am yeah well
you you do a lot of stuff at Unleashed
and your videos on on the comedy
Unleashed Channel have done very well
your own YouTube channel has grown
because of it of course strong
independent women hate Donald Trump
because his policies mean that they will
ultimately have to pay for birth control
and if there's anything as strong
independent woman really hates is to pay
for her own stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
um speaking of strong women Hillary
Clinton is still promoting her latest
book it's called what happened
in this book described by New York Times
as a feminist Manifesto Hillary explains
that she lost to Trump because American
white women could not resist persuasion
from their male family members so they
went out and voted for Trump
hate it when a feminist candidate cannot
smash the glass ceiling because of all
these millions of stupid impressionable
women standing in their way foreign
[Music]
Formula One abolished grit girls you
know grid goals were models wearing kind
of revealing skimpy clothes on on the
racetrack doing promotional activities
and after Formula One abolished them
some of these girls went on Twitter
lashed out at feminist they said we lost
our jobs because of you but I think it's
great it's great that Formula One did
that because in this day and age we can
no longer allow the patriarchy to tell
women what to do with their bodies it is
up to less attractive women
[Applause]
any any dual citizens in the room
yeah okay people ask me what is the best
thing about having been in solitary
confinement in this level
Islamic Republic of Iran
stuff um
about having been interrogated by the
notorious Iranian intelligence in a dark
cold hostile room is that this thing is
no longer the scariest experience of my
life
you can bet the scariest room I ever
experienced it was in Camden
some white women didn't get me so it got
kind of nasty anyway uh but but if I've
learned anything from Comedy the golden
rule of Comedy I'm gonna share with you
never ever blame the audience for a joke
that doesn't work because a comedian
blaming his audience
for the joke that that doesn't work is
is is like a feminist presidential
candidate blaming women
winning the elections I don't know if
this is true true or something do you
just talked about in your comedy but you
talked about like being detained in Iran
or something like that is yeah yeah well
you know they say talk about what you
know or what has happened to you and of
course it was only two weeks or
something so by Iranians two weeks more
than most people want to be fair enough
to give me you know some legitimate no
reason to joke about it or to to build
material on that but obviously anybody
coming from that country or having lived
in that country has either gone through
something similar or knows people who
have gone through my my own uh uncle was
a political prisoner for four or five
years uh over there so so yeah it's
something to talk about and what why why
did it happen to you
just a demonstration you went to a
demonstration against the government
yeah and you got arrested and put in
prison for two weeks yeah but because my
father used to work for the government
at that time you know they they give you
a hefty bail or something or your
father's job is basically the bait so he
gets out and then you try to convince
them that you were there you know just
by accident and I I did a good job of
that apparently I'm a good liar or
something well you are a comedian so
what's I mean I never thought I'd ask
this question but what's an Iranian jail
like Nicholas
uh you know often you hear about
solitary confinement I wish I had
solitary confinement because when you
are crammed you know in a big cell a big
number of people and the worst thing is
that you don't know when you're going to
get tired and of course you meet people
who are there for for for for much
longer you're you've meet people who are
potentially uh can be executed potential
spies and also all sorts of you know
um terrifying stories so it's it's not
nice and it's something some something
to give you some food for thought when
you you know like Constantine come from
a totally different dictatorial reality
to the west and you compare and contrast
the two realities and people's fears
first world problems as opposed to you
know third world problems and gives you
some perspective I imagine it does and
what what perspective does it give you
what have you found out about the West
after comparing it to your initial
experiences in Iran
uh you know that made me let's say an
atypical Italian because I was born in
Italy
um I was in Iran because my parents were
Iranian and took me out uh against my
will they had that brilliant idea of uh
giving me the opportunity to to spend my
teenage years in the Islamic Republic of
Iran so so being an atypical Italian I
never complained about food unlike the
Italians go all around the world this
food is yeah we are not in Italy food is
terrible outside Italy get over it I
never complained about food for example
that's one thing okay so you never
complain about food but look there's
there's a lot of things that people
complain about here yeah and you must
think having spent your teenage years in
the Islamic Republic of Iran yeah oh
come on guys like what what do we
complain about here that you find
ridiculous
um
well um I don't know lost baggage at the
airport
well some of these things obviously
sometimes I complain about because that
was many years ago so you were
climatized to your new to your new
environment but
um people like me who who come to the
west or return to the West because I was
born in the west anyway yeah Italy
okay it's my first time here so I'm not
gonna be too sure
um yeah uh that's the Cradle of the west
but anyway
um
um I think a lot of us
um especially coming from the Islamic
Republic are shocked to see how Islam or
Islamic views are given free reign I
joke about I say it was easier to
criticize Islam in the Islamic Republic
than in here probably safer too yeah
yeah obviously it's a joke but the idea
behind it is that
um all these um you know attitudes
towards diversity at any cost and all
cultures being equally valuable on all
World rules and of course we are seeing
the results in France so I think at the
end of the day the West needs to take a
stance and say look this is the way we
we are and this is the the reference
culture or The prominent or the
predominant culture whatever comes in
has to be in line with it or compatible
with it or respectful of it and then
maybe we can go along but dismantling
the visitors to be you know um
complacent towards the newcomers
leads to catastrophic results as we are
seeing not just in every Western
European country but more pronounced the
situation right now in France and these
are the views that have made you so
popular on the London circuit they love
me yeah yeah
yeah well uh well you had an interesting
career because you actually worked in
the BBC yeah while you were starting
your comedy career yeah and that wasn't
very easy for you was it uh definitely
not
you know because I came to London to
work as a journalist for for BBC Persian
which is the Persian TV channel
uh which is part of the BBC World
Service which broadcasts in more than 30
languages so that was my dream and as a
teenager in Iran I used to listen to the
BBC and similar radio stations as the
voice of the you know liberal West and
as a beacon of democracy and hope and
all that
and then once I got here I thought that
that the BBC obviously had changed a lot
everything is changing here you know by
even things that were acceptable five
years ago are you know
taboos today but uh yeah I just found
myself to be working for them for a
mouthpiece of uh you know globalist
agenda on on so many
areas
and of course uh when I started doing
comedy
um I did one of those Unleashed gigs and
it went well the The Spectator
run a feature run a feature it was 2020
it was entitled the best on woke Comics
to watch in lockdown and I was one of
the four on that uh article and the
article somehow made its way to my
boss's desks and they're my disciplinary
troubles started the idea was you are
jeopardizing the the good impartial name
of the the BBC and I wasn't even even a
public figure because we broadcast
overseas in a non-english language
nobody in this country knew I was
working for the BBC and I was not a
public face of the BBC but in Italy we
have a saying we say the law is applied
to the enemies and interpreted for the
friends right so you go on anything
famous BBC presenters Twitter feed most
of them the Gary linekers and other ones
and you see where they are coming from
you see what the world view is you see
what they think about immigration or
Trump or brexit and so on and so forth
but they get a free ride or free pass
whereas in my case they said no you can
you can do that and ultimately I was put
on final written warning
uh suspended from work and I thought
okay I'm I need to I need to change my
job so I got out so
did the
material and what was it about the
nature of the material was it the topic
she were talking about was it the
approach that you were talking about was
it certain jokes that they found two
hot to handle shall we say
um well there were there was more than
one disciplinary procedures and of
course they put
um the files or the complaints in front
of you and say okay what's what's going
on here and these are some of the areas
or some of the jokes so obviously the
fact that they were right-wing jokes uh
it didn't help
but but the bottom line if they wanted
to apply the letter of the law or the
letter of their terms and conditions and
that's what they wanted to do to me
was that anytime you want to go do any
performance anywhere you should come and
run the text first you need to get
permission to be in that event even if
you are just a panelist even if it's not
comedy and secondly you need to run the
your your speech or your comedy routine
by the bosses who need prior approval so
it's just imagine you are being heckled
by somebody and you want to have a you
know you want to have an answer to
somebody or you want to react to the
rumors hang on a minute I need to call
you know the BBC editorial hotline to
see if they are going to obviously it
was it was it was ridiculous and it was
a multitude of of complaints because
um I was also at loggerheads with them
over some of our content you know Trump
was in power at that time uh the Arizona
wall there was a report I I said this is
not this is not impartial
and they said when you say this is not
impartial you are questioning our
impartiality you are undermining our
impartiality by by saying this is not
important how about the guy who did an
impartial uh report on on Trump's wall
in Arizona maybe he's undermining the
impartiality
uh it was it was just ridiculous and
initially we say mathematics like
mathematics is not an Affinia I mean
it's not up for a debate so if you have
a report about about Trump's wall
and in this five minutes report you have
three people of which two are against
the wall this is already you know
lopsided never mind that the guy who is
for the wall you've gone for a you know
wacky guy with a guy you know you're
trying to depict him you know and and
one of those two in favor of the walls
is such a tender activist who is crying
while walking on these days and never
mind that your own reporter is also
against the wall
we talk to those who see Donald Trump's
border wall as a betrayal of American
ideals I just see this on a daily basis
and it sometimes just hits you
and those for whom there's no price too
high to pay to protect all they hold
dear you prepared to use that oh yeah if
it comes down to it
I'm coming home
it is this this was surreal that in this
report there's a scene in which uh Cavs
little cows are being separated from
their moms to be sold in Oklahoma as
opposed to Arizona where they are being
reared and then the reporter Compares
that to separating kids from you know
the immigrants in what universe is that
is that impartial and this sort of
juxtaposition of these two things it
takes a few hours to sort the carves for
sale headed for Oklahoma
never see their mothers again
but that's business
say over 500 children remain separated
from their families building a big wall
was only part of the plan critics in
Congress and human rights groups claimed
migrants were being treated like cattle
under Donald Trump's Zero Tolerance
child separation policy to deter illegal
migration
eventually his administration was forced
to change course anyway so So eventually
it was a it was a Soviet style or
Islamic Republic style trial where you
are you have a series of allegations
comedy being one of them but not not the
only one
and you have to be defended and I went
to the guy because I was a member of the
the nuj national Union of journalists
and our our rep said I can't defend you
because I'm a feminist and I believe in
the equality of men and women and I
thought okay I believe in the equality
of men and women as well but by the way
milosevic and Saddam Hussein got to have
defense
I'm paying 20 bucks per month for
Christ's sake yeah but so Dan didn't do
your job yeah sure sure but um
the fact is
um
Union refused to represent you yeah yeah
and I I told them you know the central
command of nuj and they said you have a
chapel at Persian TV refer to your own
Chapel my Chapel guy refused to defend
me I was defended by a another Union and
another union rep provided to me by Free
Speech Union because I was also a member
of free speech Union so I told them I
wrote to them I said this is my
situation so they gave me a a a union
rep they gave me a kind of uh psychology
course because they thought I might
because there was lockdown time so they
thought I might you know harm myself or
you know similar things because my job
was on the line and it was it was a
tough time uh so I didn't get fired on
that case it it ended up in a final
written warning but I thought look if I
want to do comedy I need to get out of
here no and didn't wasn't there an
instance as well where some comedians
were talking about reporting you or
reported you to your employer because of
some of the jokes that you did well the
first time the first time this happened
to me
um they never reveal who actually
complained but
um I was basically 11 gigs into into my
comedy career yeah very early on and I
had done a couple of uh I mean that has
to be a record Being reported to your
employer for jokes to do after 11.
that's what happens when you do my
comedy course yeah
well yeah Francis has common of course
had preferred before all the
eventualities but but the thing is I had
done a couple of open mics for this guy
this promoter and he was doing a themed
night which was politics
my good friend Irish comic or Jordan he
told me man in London when they say
politics night they mean Lefty politics
night so so I I told the guy look I'm
going to do some right-wing comedy and
he said okay it's fine I told I told him
in writing on on Facebook Messenger but
later he said I thought you were kidding
or you were a character actor so I go
there and everybody's anti-trump
basically the the MC slash promoter came
on stage and said okay let's get this
out of the way tonight this is a
post-trump election therapy night so who
is against Trump here just to make it I
was the only one who raised his hand
really and basically the Knight turned
into the roast of Nicholas DeSanto it
was no longer you know politics now
every every comedian went on there
roasted me fair enough
and then uh I did my bit didn't go down
well with with mainly the act so the ax
went to this promoted why did you have
him on and the promoter threw me under
the bus and he said when when these some
of the promoters
maybe are I still need to meet that one
who is courageous and say look I want to
cancel you because I don't agree with
you but they come up with all funny
excuses and this one was like
[Music]
um
yeah you were not accurate I don't mind
but you were not AG because this was the
joke I I used to do I was I was I would
say you know I'm a right-wing comedian
and the downside of being a right-wing
comedian is that there's no one else
whose material I can copy you know and
he was like you implied that you are the
only right-wing comedian in the country
but there's also Andrew Lawrence and Leo
curse so okay so it makes three of us
the point is still valid isn't it when
Omid jalili says I'm the only Iranian
comic in the world do they ban him
because he he claims that obviously the
point is right but anyway
so next day on his Facebook page of this
comedy um Club there was a big debate he
had a review for everybody and he gave a
bad review just for me and I thought he
was trying to be edgy but failed and I
thought you know I told you I was going
to do this and there's no need for you
to throw me under the bus so their
debate started in this public group and
then the headliner no less of that night
comes on he has researched my real
Iranian surname and I am my my day job
my employer oh don't you work for the
BBC aren't you supposed to be impartial
isn't this your name and of course soon
enough
I was I was called to my boss's office I
can't say for sure that that was
actually you know the trigger
uh but yeah he basically outed me a
fellow comic and um one thing that
really uh
annoys me is that
a lot of times it's not even the
audience who complain it's fellow Comics
or the MC
uh who just throw you under the bus and
why do you think that is Nicholas
um I don't know because
uh
being illiberal although they call
themselves liberal maybe
Envy jealousy and also
um maybe viewing comedy the way they
view any other
um activity in life as a as as people
who see themselves the lefties as
depositories of the truth right like the
Communists they have already seen the
end of times it's going to be like that
and Islam is the Same by the end
everybody will be Muslim or communist so
anything is legitimate to get rid of you
know people who don't agree with you so
it's not like okay I'm a comic I have
because this is what I like about comedy
it's the most direct form of art or
craft it's not like you do a painting
and say okay you don't you don't like it
you don't understand maybe after my
death like like Van Gogh uh I'll be
famous I'll be appreciated and people
will say I was ahead of my time in
common in stand up the reaction that the
judgment is immediate so people either
like you or they don't like you and if I
have bomb if I have bombed or when I
have bomb so I have already bumped I
have already got the verdict what is the
reason for you to go and complain to The
Venue owner or to or to my day job
employer
or or write a bad review about me which
even by the way doesn't doesn't uh I
know I'm putting a lot of meat on the
grill like we say in Italy but this is
another thing I did a competition I was
in the final of Natty's new Act of the
years at at um Hackney Empire it's very
prestigious competition yeah thank you
to this day is my best result
competition wise I was in the final
uh I didn't win but I was a finalist I
have the clip and I got two Applause
breaks and an evening standard that the
reviewer says oh yeah people as soon as
right wing comic uh Nicholas DeSanto
came on stage people slumped back in
their church I have it on tape I have
two Applause breaks in in five minutes
so why why would you lie anyway you know
so to get back to your question I think
any means is
um legitimate for them just to
bring you down which which
um to put it quite concisely cancer
culture they just want to cancel you
hey KK do you like trigonometry of
course I do incredible interviews
fascinating guests phenomenal live shows
and hilarious raw streams in that case
you need to join our locals so you can
have access to even more brilliant
content that's right you get the chance
to win incredible prizes ask our
phenomenal guests your questions access
extra content and now the only place to
watch our Roars on catch up is on locals
our war shows still go out at 7pm UK
time 2 p.m Eastern as normal but if you
want to watch some after this time then
you're gonna need to sign up to our
locals Ross have now become too spicy to
stay on YouTube so they're only
available to watch back on our locals
page all you need to do to sign up is
click on the link below this video and
for just seven dollars a month you have
access to All of This brilliant content
seven dollars a month even for someone
of my persuasion that's a bargain see
fuel on locals
and it's interesting as well because I
remember following that because I knew
you and I liked you and I thought you
showed great promise as a comment you
were very funny thanks and but I
remember looking at this particular
Facebook group because it popped up on
my feed and they were openly talking
about it yeah and what what what gave me
some encouragement and some some comfort
was that some some fellow comics and
promoters who we live in London tend to
be if anything uh lefties or you know
left oriented actually came out in my
support some privately some publicly you
know Alfie Knox is another London
promoter he's he's a raging you know
Lefty
um but he kept giving me spots he said
you know I want you to come come on
stage you have something different to
say and it's important you know for for
you know that's that's true diversity if
you like you know so it wasn't all all
bad
thankfully but um that's the sort of
circuit that we are we are dealing with
and I'm sure you're well aware as well
yeah and it's not the first time as well
you told me about a very prestigious
Comedy Club when you were if you
remember when we were on the phone
having a chat with each other yeah talk
about that because I couldn't believe
this
uh yeah hey this one is near near Crouch
and I live in North London so I like
this club very nice venue quite by
London standards local to me uh we used
to do this um obviously this was again
my my early days
and um they I would do this Tuesday or
Thursday night which was sort of an open
mic for which uh tickets were sold but
open marketers wouldn't get paid because
the the premise being that okay you are
just learning the ropes and you are not
maybe good enough to be paid but we give
you the opportunity fair enough and I
like that I did that a couple of times
and it went well the third time I do it
I try a couple of pro-life jokes uh
didn't go well a surprise surprise and
the owner actually was not in that night
but he records all all performances and
next time I call him to get a spot he
says no somebody complained he never
said who complained I I suspect it was
the MC no less but I can be sure uh
because DMC right after me went on stage
and uh threw me over under the bus
anyway but uh and I I said yeah
um you you true you you you did these
pro-life
um jokes these anti-abortion shows have
you or your wife girlfriend had ever had
abortion or something no that's I'm a
anti-abortion what what does that have
to do with anything and I said no I
don't mind right wing talking about
excuse it I don't mind right-wing but
you are not funny I'm not supposed to be
funny that's why you don't pay us
because it's open mic was the guy
talking about Trump's small hand funny
was the guy talking about Trump's funny
hair funny again these were these were
Trump years
so can I come back maybe in six months
no you have it seems to me that you have
taken this path and no so indefinitely
indefinitely
um
banned and he later won an award at
Turtle the one of the fun
um most uh known comedy Publications in
the UK for the most supportive venue or
the most supportive you know behind the
scenes uh promoter but but yeah that's
also another episode but it's great that
you have company Unleashed which are
giving you spots and the videos that
they put out of you have done really
really well yeah I mean I'm very
grateful comedy unleash is really one of
a handful of venues around London uh who
give me or people like me uh a platform
to to perform of course it's a very nice
club backyard comedy club uh big room
professionally they film it and thank
God for for YouTube or rumble or
alternative platforms because then you
get some some validation encouragement
people all around the world see my uh my
videos somebody invited me from the US
to go and do a private gig for them last
October so so that's been nice I did
this
um the pro-life set in in January
but I think the right sort of Americans
shared it a couple of months later uh
and somehow the algorithm the gods of
the algorithm were kind to me and it uh
picked up and it's been seen 700 10 000
times so far
and so I got a lot of positive feedback
from people in Australia India mostly in
America so so that's been good
Disney Corporation is paying uh travel
expenses for its uh employees so they
can travel to Blue States and get an
abortion I mean Disney produces content
for children and now they're subsidizing
the killing of children right
it doesn't make sense you're killing
your own future customers like it's like
it's like Central London declaring war
on Russian oligarchs
so so Disney in a statement Disney said
we are doing this because we understand
women's Reproductive Rights what we
don't understand is irony
foreign
but now in America Planned Parenthood
they are coming with mobile abortion
clinics they are using these RV wagons
uh turning them into Mobile abortion
clinics driving close to the borders of
the red states trying to lure pregnant
women to these clinics I mean that is
some serious commitment isn't it these
these must really really love killing
black babies
because they're all black the mostly you
know every second uh black baby in
America is aborted did you know that
right you can try wrong laugh
okay
you can try not to laugh but you cannot
not learn
yeah
I mean even the Nazis were not like that
they didn't come up with you know the
iconic Volkswagen Camper vans driving
close to the Swiss border with their
Mobile Gas Chambers trying to tempt the
Swiss
to give up their Jews the Nazis had
principles
we have we have we haven't the principle
the principle if we if we conquer the
land fair and square we exterminate
otherwise we don't just drive and
they didn't do that
but by the way what sort of messed up
cynical name is it Planned Parenthood
because there's no planning and there's
no Parenthood yeah I'm planning to
become a parent okay let's start with
killing your baby by the time you leave
the clinic there is no Parenthood
it's like I am planning my visit to
Australia and I start by shredding my
tickets to Australia
it's I think it's a great
um
um development if you like that nowadays
Comics up and coming Comics like me
that's the term isn't it do not totally
rely on the traditional Gatekeepers of
Truth and funniness being it's the the
TV producers or the usual
comedy club promoter the thing is I
don't know whether this was always true
but in my time I during all the
competitions and all the clubs and
whatever and I'm not speaking about
myself I never had any issue with that
but I always saw that the people they
were picking were not necessarily the
funniest people but they were the people
who fit whatever was the view at the
time of what comedy should be exactly
right so somebody could go on and Crush
but it didn't really matter because the
people who were picking the comedy
winners or the who gets to go on a TV
show or whatever they tended to pick who
they agreed with you know whose comedy
they thought represented the future of
Comedy whatever the [__] that means
exactly right it's a bit like the Oscars
or a chance yeah but and it's so
fulfilling because they're the ones that
decide what the future of Comedy is by
picking the people they have decided are
going to be the future of Comedy so they
set the taste and they said well they
don't set the taste because the people
stopped watching the shows but they set
the the way that that was being done and
as you say where we are now
no you don't need Gatekeepers you've got
uh your YouTube channel is growing
nicely you went from like seven thousand
to thirty thousand off the back of one
video the one you're talking about uh
you'll get some more views after this
I'm sure
um so this is the exciting thing that I
think not enough people really are
taking advantage of is like there are no
Gatekeepers that can stop you making
good content on the internet yeah and
then you can make whatever you want and
then well I mean in Leo's case you still
can't talk because they won't give you a
venue but broadly speaking the like the
idea still worked which is you can
create your own stuff exactly and it it
helps you in terms of legitimacy in
terms of validation some sort of
gratification and motivation to give you
the force to go ahead because it's it's
a big sacrifice you know I'm not a 20
year old I have a family to support I
need to get out of the house you know
travel uh take time off my uh family my
my kids and it has to be obviously
content-wise it has to be something
worth it and that's why I with all due
respect and I respect people who do
everyday mundane aspects funny but I
don't talk about you know airline food
or Tinder or dating or or because
somebody else might be doing it better
than than I am already but
um but what I think is that
um again going back to my background
maybe it wasn't a huge deal for me being
canceled from this club or that club it
was obviously very annoying and very
perplexing no no doubt about that but
um for someone who has been in jail
albeit for two weeks and has worked with
a maybe an Iranian TV channels seeing
images of Destruction and you know Mass
Graves and because that's that's the
news when you covered you there there's
so much worse that you've seen that
maybe being you know uh grasped by your
fellow comic to your day job is not the
most traumatic experience of your life
but but similar uh episodes can really
discourage and put off another young
comic who comes on and the the circuit
or the the competition results or judges
or reviewers treat him as if his
material is not worth and he might just
you know give it up whereas if you have
some alternative platforms you think oh
maybe I am doing something right maybe I
have something to say maybe if they say
okay you have never been on the BBC or
comedy Center okay no but but this is my
channel this is my uh you know uh uh
followership so so it is a new source of
an alternative source of legitimacy and
motivation which is which is very
important absolutely and also as well
what was a disadvantage to you on the
comedy circuit because you had a
different way of looking at the world
you joked about different subjects all
of a sudden you go online people want
that content they're thirsty for it
because they're not getting it elsewhere
and it's all about turning talk about
turning a disadvantage into an
opportunity right it makes you more
memorable a lot of people even on on
London Comedy Circus sometimes people
may be secretly but after the show in
the interval they come to me say oh
thank God I I I agree but I would have
never dared saying what you're saying or
you are so this is your comedy is so
refreshing right and similar thing on on
YouTube or or elsewhere people are tired
of same old same old because the the
comedy Gatekeepers have decided that
yeah this year or these five years it's
all about comedians talking about their
struggles with mental health
well your show is is is is worthy
because your show is about your racist
dad who eventually comes to accept that
you know gays or non-whites are cool so
this is your show so so they won't just
they they use comedy uh as a vehicle for
carrying the specific message or agenda
which would have been fun because I do
the same thing but they they are giving
their the the the the the airwaves and
the stage time to only that sort of
message you know and call it diversity
at the same time so
so so yes basically
um people are are have a thirst for this
kind of content and if they don't I mean
we we know clubs are not doing so well
for for a variety of reasons but this is
one of them obviously kovi didn't help
Netflix uh TV on demand doesn't help uh
clubs are struggling
um Netflix is struggling
um Saturday Saturday Night Live is
struggling
um
so people people are looking for a
different message and a different kind
of Comedy the way comedy was supposed to
be yeah and Nicholas and
why are you right wing
haha
well
I guess a lot of it has to has to do
with my with my background
um again maybe nobody is right being on
every issue and left wing on every issue
but
um Mass immigration
is is a big problem for me you don't
want competition
Iranian Italians coming over here
exactly exactly I mean how many do we
need I'm already here because oh so you
came here you came here and you don't
want what do you think I got away from
them in the first place if they have you
know
um there's some some some comedy vein in
there and more importantly from Italian
perspective you know
if if you drop a couple of
um water drops in a glass of wine wine
is still wine but if the glass of wine
becomes twenty percent thirty percent
forty percent water it's no longer wine
you know so I think
uh it is important uh for as I alluded
to this at the beginning
that the identity and the demographics
of these countries be protected because
anywhere else in the world it's
sacrosanct but when it comes to white
people when it comes to Western Nations
when it comes it comes to White
Europeans
it's it's suddenly taboo and it's and
it's racist to to to to to to have this
desire to preserve your your brethren to
preserve your culture to preserve your
language your way of life and your
ideals anywhere else in the world
is acceptable is encouraged right nobody
goes to Nigeria saying why aren't you
taking more migrants or why don't you
have more white people on your on your
TV shows nobody goes to say the same
thing to Japan or Malaysia or anywhere
else
um so so that's that and of course I'm
in favor of smaller government uh less
intrusion from the government these are
other right-wing talking points
Traditional Values family I think
traditional family is is really under
threat uh marriage so a series of a
series of
um talking points and areas where I find
myself on the on the conservative side
and you said the did you say families
under threat or the Traditional Values
on the threat well both of them and what
do you mean by that
um well we know nowadays the definition
of family has become overstretched you
know uh marriage is no longer what it
was uh we have so much divorce we have
single Parenthood single motherhood
actively encouraged
um if you look at the U.S but not just
the US say single moms are voting Biden
so Biden is the daddy of these kids and
they call themselves independent I mean
I talked about this in Newcastle didn't
go down so well
I'm talking about the phenomy if if you
have if you're who's a CEO of
trigonometry she's going to be livid but
anyway you carry on oh okay I carry on
at my own risk but um I mean if if your
husband or the the your partner was a
jerk and he left you or God forbid
something happened to him or whatever
it's fine but I'm talking about the
phenomenon
single mother by choice they have their
Facebook groups and everything yeah I
want to raise a child on my own
independently I don't need a dad so
maybe I just get pregnant by by somebody
or or go to the sperm bank and I raise
it independently and you're on benefits
in what universe is it Independence
everybody is paying
for for you to raise this child
independently without thinking about the
consequences I believe the child ideally
needs a father and the mother okay not
just one mother not two mothers or two
fathers uh then of course if it's an
orphan in in an orphanage you can argue
okay what is best to have at least one
parent rather than growing up in an
orphanage I get that but when we see
that our culture our mainstream media
our content providers be it maybe
Hollywood the film industry comedy
circuit they encourage women to do it on
their own without a dad but of course
off the back of the taxpayer I don't
think this is the right uh the right
path
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
I don't think
[Music]
um
the the traditional family needs to be
undermined because their results will be
will be catastrophic and I think
as our
current Italian Prime Minister who is a
Woman by the way and not much to the
liking of feminists
she said something
um along these lines that these Global
forces they want to make everything
relative everything a social construct
everything arbitrary devoid us we we
become devoid of all elements of
identity because then it's easier to to
dominate us when everybody becomes
somebody who is beige so race doesn't
matter
culture doesn't matter gender doesn't
matter because when gender becomes
arbitrary and you can change it
any moment you feel like then it's it's
not a defining element of your identity
when you have nothing they go after
religion they go after family they go
after nationality and nationalism
patriotism they go after all these
things so we all become atomized right
individuals just looking to consume as
much as possible and work for minimum
wage
or less than minimum wage because they
have also removed the borders so you
can't demand rights because the guy is
coming from that third world country who
is happy to work for Less so so
ultimately
um it's easier for them to to dominate
us and to enslave us and that's why I
think the attack on on family
traditional family and family values is
is another is another step in that
direction I respect individual choice if
you want to be single or if you want to
you know uh uh not have children
that's fine but when it's actively
encouraged by the government with
taxpayers money to to promote an agenda
as as an equally viable and valuable
lifestyle that is a problem ultimately
to to preserve our identity our nation
our population our way of life we need
to reproduce and we need to raise kids
in the best environment possible that is
a traditional family with Traditional
Values with respect for potentially
different ways of life or potentially
different choices but when you turn on
the TV or go to the comedy club or watch
Hollywood or listen to the news
and it's like yeah Love Is Love uh two
fathers or two mothers are the same as
one father one mother
right
um don't have kids
a couple of weeks ago I had my first
appearance on on GB news Headliners
right that was my TV debut and one of
the stories was about
um this dating app in France which
um targets uh the niche
probably we can't call it Niche but
um right Wingers or Patriots people who
want traditional Partners or
traditionally oriented Partners women
who want to have kids raise a
traditional family and so on
and This this term was actually
mentioned
in in the article
the great replacement Theory
um so I raised it because it was in the
art it wasn't even my my personal
contribution
um the idea was that some of these uh
women or men in France who go after this
who who subscribe to this dating app
they see it
um with a view to counter the
replacement uh great replacement
whereby according to this Theory our
overlords want to wipe off uh White
Europeans in their own homelands by
migration and replacement and so on so
instead they want to have kids as as
white Europeans and I mentioned that and
then I clipped it and put it on my
YouTube channel and YouTube has come up
with a with an impartial fact-checking
Wikipedia box underneath that saying oh
the great replacement theory is a
conspiracy theory
and I'm thinking is it though because
feminists say don't have kids women go
and have careers environmentally say
because of Net Zero don't have kids and
the government makes it damn
difficult to have kids with their
policies I I think the the the point
that they're making uh Nicholas is this
I think the great conspiracy theory says
that there's this overarching the reason
it's a conspiracy theory is that these
these people in charge and they're the
ones pulling the levers and they want
white Europeans you know absolutely the
population decimated when I think and
you as an intelligent man would agree
with me or maybe you don't I don't know
that actually the reality is always far
more complex than that it's never you
know these people are in charge and
they're enacting all this change every
everything is complex obviously I mean I
never thought that there's there has
been a room or maybe in Davos they get
together and say okay now how can we
wipe out white Europeans in these steps
you know according to this roadmap I
think the whole depopulation thing I
mean we've had people on the show
Stephen Shaw who made a documentary
about the depopulation bomb a lot of it
is driven by technology economics and
things of that nature and actually when
even if this idea was true when and when
people like me and you come to the West
first generation we have kids second
generation don't have kids either so
you're not long-term going to replace
white people because when the non-white
people get here
they engage in all the same behavior
because it's a cultural economic
um well depends what what what what what
is the number of the input
because yeah in countries like Germany
or maybe even Italy I'm not sure about
that
um they are maybe moving towards
um
reaching the the so-called replacement
rate okay the bare minimum but it's
mainly down to immigrants yeah yeah
um and they openly tell you they say
okay we need more immigrants
because women are not having enough kids
okay now whose fault is that you know
you give me a five percent mortgage it's
always meant yeah
no it's because the government The
Government Can can encourage
uh repopulation it's very hard though I
mean if you look at all the evidence
it's very very difficult in Hungary they
literally threw the kitchen sink at it
and they increased it by like 0.2
percent or something it's it's very
difficult to change what are
technologically and economically and
culturally driven things from the
government coming in and and trying to
encourage people well I'm all for that
by the way I actually really think
depopulation is a big problem I also
think people not having children you
know this because you're a dad
um people not having children preserves
the state of immaturity for a lot longer
and so we live in societies that
increasingly become immature people
don't think long term people aren't
thinking well if we borrow build
trillions and trillions of dollars from
the future what's going to be the
consequence of that because they're not
thinking about about the future I agree
with all of that unfortunately it seems
to be very difficult to actually change
that yeah it might be very difficult but
I think again government and culture and
a lot of our culture is government
sanctioned or government funding can
change that again to to link it to our
comedy
um environment when you have you have
Comics who actively say oh yeah I don't
I don't have children what a great life
it is you know I was enjoying my Pinot
Grigio or or you know you have
advertising all over the place yeah you
can you can buy this sweater with uh on
on on three payments uh you know
if if you are buying sweaters on
installments maybe you should re
re-evaluate your maybe you don't you
don't need to buy stuff that much stuff
you know you you you you turn on
television how many apps do we have
right now which is about people
decluttering their wardrobes how many
startups you know maybe we should we
should not encourage this consumerism
in in the first place
you see what I mean yeah uh so so the
the government the same government that
decides to actively change our way of
life when it comes to uh diesel when it
comes to consumption CO2 generation be
it based on real facts or another
generalist let's not maybe go there but
the same government who actively put us
under on their house arrest
for a year or so the same government are
telling me that they cannot encourage
people to have children by providing
them with you know Creations maternity
leave better maternity
conditions more kindergartens nurseries
they of course they can do that because
they are there they are hell-bent on
changing our way of life in other areas
aren't they yeah look they they are you
can say that they are hell-bent on
changing our way of life in other ways
but I think the if I'm being honest with
you Nicholas I think the problem is
actually far more complex than
you're giving it credit for and like
Constantine said using the example of
Hungary it is very very difficult to do
because if you look at practically every
industrialized Nation not just in the
west but you look at uh South Korea I
think they've got a replacement rate of
between 0.8 and 0.9 so I mean that is
dire and actually far worse than our own
and if you look at China China A lot of
people are saying is on the precipice of
almost population collapse so what is
happening is not just a western issue
it's the issue of industrialized nations
no I get that and I agree and but your
point though sorry it's interesting the
point is broadly I understand what
you're saying because you're right when
you turn on your TV when you go to a
comedy club when you listen to the media
the cultural message is not one of kids
are great and let's have more right and
I this is why even though I don't like
putting and I don't put photos of my son
up with his face on social media I am
constantly pumping out like Q family
things because I want people to see that
you can do this and it's it's great and
I want men to know that as well because
I think men increasingly haven't been
told that too so I'm kind of using that
to to put out a different cultural
message and I think that's that's what
you're talking about and that I
completely agree with yeah just just to
try to show that you know rather than
um excessive consumerism yeah
and just concentrating on your career
until you get to the age of 40 and maybe
that then it's a bit too late uh to have
a child uh there is an alternative and
we call it alternate but this is a
traditional way of life it used to be
like that until 25 minutes ago so that
can be encouraged as well now if if
again
um if we had a government who was like
you know yeah I'm hands off you do
whatever you want like I would have I
would have bought that I don't think
they are doing all they can in in and
this is all all over the West more or
less you know because a lot of time
oftentimes young people want to have
kids but they're just saying okay if I
have a kid then what about the housing
problem what about my my income what
about the the nursery situation yeah
yeah it's an economic problem largely as
well uh Nicholas we've had a very
serious conversation which uh May
confuse some people about the fact uh
that you are actually a very good
comedian who people should check out uh
tell everybody before we go to locals
and I ask you some bonus questions uh
where can people find you online and
follow you and follow your work okay my
YouTube channel is called Anglo Italian
comedy
um this the same name for rumble if
that's um uh of people's alley on and on
Twitter I'm at Nico underscore de Santo
perfect and uh we always end up with the
same question uh which is what is the
one thing that we're not talking about
as a society that you think really
should be well I've already used
so I think our 911 wasn't real exactly
it's the Jews Inside Job okay I just I
might need to do some gigs in Israel at
some point I'm not going to go there but
I think
um
clearly not having the situation of um
the the demographic decline that we
already exhaustively uh covered
um I think what uh
is
alarming to me is the situation where is
is the way family courts are biased
against fathers when you get to divorce
and it happens a lot more more more
often than uh we all would like to see
as you know uh the system is is very
much stacked up against men when it
comes to custody and when it comes to uh
recognizing their rights as a father and
this is again something apparently in
America for sure in the UK I know for
sure
um probably it's a Common Thread along
the uh Across the Western World
um that's that's something that needs to
be dealt with
perfect Nicholas DeSanto thank you very
much follow us over to locals where
we'll continue the conversation
like as a younger brother
[Music]